this movie is more immersive visually or
challenging visually and there are some
things in it that are super bonkers for
the IMAX experience IMAX just by itself
but is the best way to see cinema I
created something terrible artificial
intelligence
oh my god I can't imagine saying that's
an IMAX I've gotta see that you know I
think it's about time yeah I'll see how
the Internet written rent lodge it's
like a movie on stare it's jam-packed
you're not just like looking at one
thing and actually happening on the
ground you get to see some emotion
throughout the whole street
I mean it's like nice chatting it's
those moments that fans want as we
mister I loved it like those moments
that wanted to begin any company little
couple man where everybody is just
involved at once you see the whole team
fighting as a unit those are gonna be
fun and I bet I max these are like the
movies like need to be saved with a lot
of people on a big screen like the sound
the visuals it's like why people like
going to the cinema
I want people to immerse themselves the
way you can in a great review here we
all are nothing without wit and our will
these films that have gotten bigger and
bigger on every single point I think if
you're gonna go see any movie
Vidya this one you're just there to see
it on an IMAX screen mind blown
you know it's it's why we go to the
movies